this video is sponsored by squarespace
on this channel i try and bring you
content from some really beautiful spots
around my local area we've been to the
chiltons some really amazing hills we've
been all over oxfordshire and also to
oxford itself the city centre which is a
beautiful stunning historic city today
i'm coming to you from my bog welcome to
one of my weirdest videos yet and that's
saying something so the title of this
video is exercises that you can do
whilst you're brushing your teeth and of
course the whole idea is that i'm going
to be looking at different moves and
exercises you can do whilst you brush
your teeth they're gonna offer you some
kind of really useful benefit yeah this
video is something a little bit
different a little bit of fun but i
think there's a kernel of useful truth
in here as well and hopefully some
things we can learn i talked in a recent
video about how just 10 minutes of
training a day could make a big
difference to your life but if you brush
your teeth for three minutes twice a day
which is absolutely what you should be
doing that's six minutes a day that's
still a decent chunk out of those 10
minutes and 6 minutes a day of course is
42 minutes a week that's how long you
spend brushing your teeth that's not
nothing so you might as well do
something useful whilst you're doing it
it's like i say this is really just a
bit of fun do i actually do this myself
well yes and no i go through phases
where i will do this and i go through
phases where i don't but the the ethos
the general concept behind it is
something that i do believe in strongly
that's moving throughout the day
training throughout the day and finding
opportunities to work on stuff that i
mean i find interesting and cool and
that's going to benefit you outside of
your training i do pistol squats in the
shower sometimes i always get into a
resting squat when i'm changing my kids
or playing with them on the floor so
there are plenty of opportunities to
work on these things and to get
incredible benefits without having this
hours-long workout now of course this is
by no means a complete list this is my
personal list of exercises i think are
good to do whilst you brush your teeth
i'd love to hear your ideas in the
comments down below before we begin
though i do want to set a few ground
rules first of all this must be
something that you can practically do in
the bathroom whilst you're doing your
teeth on a regular basis of course you
can do pretty much any exercise whilst
you're brushing your teeth you could go
to the gym and do box jumps but you
probably end up choking on the brush and
it's just not a good idea all round i
excluded lunges for example because
there's just not enough space and squats
you're moving up and down too quickly
it's too dynamic you'd end up like not
brushing your teeth properly so we also
need to be able to brush our teeth
properly whilst doing these exercises
without any further ado let's begin
so the first exercise is horse stance or
mabu
looks like i can practice horse stance
here
yeah i'll give it a shot
this is an exercise i've been using
recently both thanks to your
recommendations in the comments but also
thanks to the awesome hybrid
calisthenics of course it's a movement
from kung fu it's also used in a bunch
of other martial arts i did tai chi so i
had a little bit of experience with it
the idea is that you're getting into a
slightly deep kind of squat slightly
wider than the squat toes pointing
forwards and this is fantastic for
strengthening the tendons and for
improving hip mobility and for
developing more core and hip strength
for developing power whether you're
throwing kicks or punches this is
something that can undo a lot of damage
caused by sitting especially if you have
poor mobility when it comes to the side
splits and if you progressively widen
your stance during the horse stance you
can actually eventually gain the size
bits from this alone see fitness faqs
for fantastic video on this
what you're going to do is stand with
your feet together then you're going to
step out about the length of one leg to
one side with one of your feet keep the
feet pointing forward and then you're
just going to sit down into that
position and you should start to feel a
tightness in your hips a good target to
aim for to begin with is 30 seconds or
60 seconds so you're not even gonna last
a full brushing of your teeth giving you
time to do something else as well but as
you get really really good at this some
people can hold it for up to an hour and
obviously they're going to experience
some real power in those kicks those
hips also really important is to keep
your back straight if you're not sure if
it's straight or not you can try against
the wall just to check and if you need
to come up a little bit higher to keep
your back straight then that's
preferable
speaking of which i made a whole video
discussing the extreme benefits of doing
lots of resting squats four minutes at a
time so i'm not gonna go into a lot of
detail here and go check that one out
but basically this will improve your
range of motion your hip mobility your
ankle mobility your knee strength it's
going to help to get into a deeper squat
it's going to help you explode higher
when you're jumping so it will translate
to better athletic performance a better
energy throughout the day lower chance
of injury all that really really good
stuff six minutes of squatting a day
even just three minutes of squatting a
day is a perfect example of something
that can really make a big difference
that's a lot of mobility work and it's
going to translate to all sorts of
improved performance so this is one that
i highly recommend
sticking for a moment with our weird
squats another great option is the
quasi-isometric squat which again i've
talked about in the past so i won't go
into in a lot of detail but basically
this is a really slow motion repetition
what these really slow repetitions do is
that they not only target the slow
twitch muscle fiber but they also allow
you to control the movement all the way
through so you're not allowing momentum
to help you're changing the strength
curve in a big way and because we're
going so slow of course that also makes
it
far more well suited to brushing our
teeth because we're not bouncing around
all over the place and you can try
widening your stance
doing all kinds of other cool stuff as
well more leg exercises that you can do
whilst you're brushing your teeth and
obviously legs lend themselves
particularly well to this is the calf
raise so a calf raise of course just
means coming up on your toes and you
normally would do this at deficit so
your toes are higher than your heel when
you go all the way down
that's easy enough to implement your
bathroom if you've got some kind of
block hanging around these are some
little shelves you could keep that in
your bathroom that's not too
inconvenient but you could also just do
it off the floor it's better than
nothing a lot of people have trouble
growing their carbs and this is also
something that i personally have
struggled with and if you're one of
those people you might be interested in
a method to bust through that plateau
which is to perform a hundred car
phrases every single day and people
report miraculous results from this this
is the perfect opportunity to perform a
hundred repetitions because you just
stood here you're bored you can do it on
the spot and three minutes or six
minutes is more than enough to perform
100 repetitions in a day
alternatively you could do it on one leg
you could do half of your brushing on
one leg and half of your brushing on the
other leg or of course you could do the
first toothbrush of the day on one leg
and the second on the other i hope this
demonstrates the pound the benefit of
incorporating these movements into a
routine because it's all very well and
good to say i'm going to do this every
single day but remembering to do that
can be tricky whereas if you tie it to
an existing routine such as brushing
your teeth it becomes much much easier
to do you can even include a post-it
note on your window or your mirror to
remind you to do it you can also do the
antagonist movement of this which is the
tibialis rays you're going to lean
against the wall put your weight on your
ankles and then dorsiflex raise your
toes up to the sky this trains the
anterior tibialis the muscle on the
front of the shin and this is really
good for absorbing impact when you're
running and jumping it's something that
ben patrick nisopatos guy talks about a
lot so if an athlete can get shin
splints so if you have knee problems
this is a great way to combat those
things or prevent them from happening in
the first place again i've talked about
this in previous videos and something
else i like to do is to brush my teeth
with my non-dominant hand in my case
that's the left hand i'm an advocate for
ambidexter training i think it's great
whether you're trying to build more
symmetrical muscle whether you're
sparring it's also just a fantastic way
to train your brain and actually to
encourage plasticity to release some
plasticity promoting neurotransmitters
so that you're a little bit more plastic
and more susceptible to learning once
you've left the bathroom this is a great
way to do that because brushing your
teeth is such a complex task in terms of
fine motor control and this is also
really good if like me you've been
accused by your dentist of brushing too
hard because it forces you to actually
brush a little bit more gently
and if you're going to be brushing your
teeth with both hands this now means you
can perform exercises using that spare
hand without becoming asymmetrical so in
this case i've already said i don't
really recommend doing bicep curls or
anything like that you could use bands
but again it's a bit impractical
something you can do is just a bit of
grip training and this is great because
grip strength as we know translates to
strength in pretty much every other
regard so you can be doing that whilst
you're brushing your teeth and this also
creates a
kind of
unique challenge in terms of
concentration trying to split and divide
your attention between those two things
so there you go guys that's my selection
like i said i'd love to know any of your
ideas of course this has been a little
bit of a gimmick but like i say i hope
it illustrates just the many myriad
opportunities we have to train
throughout the day and how beneficial
this can actually be even if it's just a
small amount and if you combine this
with a little bit of exercise whilst
you're boiling the kettle a little bit
of exercise whilst you're changing a
nappy you can get all sorts of cool
benefits in terms of mobility your focus
your mood your energy levels as well as
even your strength so definitely
something to consider and if you like
this video maybe i'll consider a
follow-up you know the top exercises you
can do whilst you're on the phone for
example let me know if that's something
you'd like to see in the comments down
below we'll see how this one performs if
you like this unique approach to
training you might enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 the pro team performance
system that's a massive ebook also comes
with over two hours of video tutorials
and the aim is to train you not only in
terms of your aesthetics not only in
terms of your strength on a few lifts
but in terms of every aspect of your
performance as much as possible check
that in the description down below if
you're interested subscribe if you want
to see more like this hit the bell
button if you want to be notified of
future videos and like this one if you
want to help me out it does really help
me out by the way guys thank you so much
for watching this one and i'll see you
next time
bye for now
when it comes to opportunity to be
productive in the bathroom they're a few
better than sitting on the bog it's no
made up statistic to say that over 98 of
all business is done on the toilet and
whilst you're here what better work to
do than to set up your own website using
squarespace today's sponsor so
squarespace is a platform that allows
anyone to build a website using zero
code and with no technical expertise it
makes it extremely simple and has all
the features you could possibly need
members only areas for easy monetization
of your website social media integration
for pushing content from your social
media pages and even e-commerce for
selling products from your site and this
is made even more powerful with
third-party extensions which allow for
things like tracking for global shipping
managing taxes and all kinds of other
stuff there's member management inbuilt
email communication analytics and a
fully featured commenting system
powerful blogging tools for creating and
sharing content for categorizing your
posts and scheduling publishing
resulting in a really modern and great
looking website whoever you are so go to
squarespace for a free trial and when
you're ready to launch bioneer viewers
can get 10 off the purchase of their
first website or domain by going to
squarespace.com forward slash bioneer
today check it out in the description
down below thanks again to squarespace
for sponsoring this video and thank you
so much to you guys for sticking around
right till the very end it really makes
a big difference to me
you